I've just arrived in Sydney Australia a
few hours ago I'm here for conference
and to do a lecture tour all around
Australia talking about chemistry
sometimes talking about our videos on
YouTube and you might well ask why does
a professor really have to come right
across the world for a conference just
to give a short lecture my lectures 45
minutes and the answer is I could have
done the video lecture but I can't talk
to all the chemists the chemical
engineers without coming here so I'm
really here to talk to people to find
out about Australian science and there's
some very good chemistry
excellent polymer chemistry all sorts of
things and some very good engineering as
well and I'm really lucky that Brady
who's you know as Australian is here as
well for part of the time so we're going
to be making some videos as well I'm
just off the plane and we were already
looking at the best view in Sydney and
we're really lucky because one of our
youtube fans mr. Gary Malloy who teaches
chemistry here as inter Louis's school
in Sydney has come in on Saturday so
that we can come up onto the roof so we
can hear about what he's teaching and we
can look at the view it's really good
mr. Maloy shows our videos to his
students he's even encouraging other
teachers in New South Wales here in
Australia to use the videos and because
I'm making videos I thought in my
luggage I would bring one of my models
one of my dog toys so I've got my Wiggly
giggly and if you watch some of our
other videos you may see it or even hear
it I'm about to start the conference
then I'm going on my lecture tour and
when I get back to the UK most of the
videos we've made here will be uploaded
so that you'll be able to watch mr.
Molloy will be able to watch and so will
his pupils and I hope we'll all learn
some chemistry